翻訳: Koichiro YODA
校正: Hiroko Kawano
（右腕の動きに合わせたバスドラム音）
（左腕の動きに合わせたハンドクラップ音）
（バスドラム音）（ハンドクラップ音）
（音楽終わり）
（左右の足の動きに合わせた電子音）
（バスドラム音）（スクラッチ音）（電子音）
（音楽終わり）
（右腕と両足の動きに合わせたロボット音）
（左腕の動きに合わせた蒸気音）
（ロボット音）（蒸気音）
（音楽終わり）
はい みなさまこんにちは
（拍手）
こんにちは はじめまして
楠太吾と申します
いきなりこんな大きい音を出して
ちょっと何やねんこれと
びっくりされたかと思うんですけれども
これはですね 実は
僕が今付けているこれで
動くことによって音を鳴らしていました
これは 僕が初めて開発したプロダクトで
踊ることによって音楽を奏でるという
コンセプトで作ったものになります
はい
で 今日は
「中途半端な第一歩が切り開く未来」
というテーマで
これを開発した経験を元に
お話しさせていただきます
「中途半端」っていう言葉
みなさんどんなイメージがありますかね？
中途半端
「お前 中途半端な奴やな」とか
「お前 中途半端やから
あかんねん」みたいな
なんかその「中途半端＝悪」みたいな
悪いイメージがすごい
ついているかと思うんですけれども
僕は中途半端というのは
すごい 時として大事な言葉じゃないかな
というふうに思っています
もしかしたら場合によっては
本当に完璧よりも
中途半端にすべき場合も
あるんじゃないかな
というようなことを考えています
で 先ほどからですね
本当に偉そうにここでお話しさせて
いただいているんですけれども
ほんの３年前ぐらいまではですね
ほんと どうしようもない
もうダメダメな社会人でした
もう仕事に全くやる気がなくて
で 遅刻するわ
たらだら仕事するわで
上司からは
「お前みたいなやつ前代未聞や！」と
「お前みたいなやつは辞めてまえ！」
って言われるぐらい
ほんと ダメダメな社会人でした
その時の僕の心境としては
「なんで今この仕事してんのかな俺？」と
自分のやりたいことも
人生をどう生きていいかもわからないまま
本当に悶々とした日々を
ただ過ごしていました
［俺は何にこの命を
燃やすべきなのか？］
何か自分のやりたいことを
見つけるために
「ちっちゃい時 何が好きやったかな？」
というのを
ちょっと振り返って
考えてみることにしたんですね
で これ ちっちゃい方が
僕なんですけれども
どちらかというとスポーツは苦手で
どっちかというと絵を書いたりとか
モノを作ったりとか
そういうのが好きな子どもで
そういうのを思い出して
「あ 俺 何かモノを生み出すような
仕事ができたら
すごいハッピーに生きられるかも？」
と ようやくここで気付いたんですね
で 成長していく過程で
次 これ大学時代なんですけれども
この矢印が僕なんですけれども
だいぶ見た目
変わっちゃったんですけれども
［大学時代 全国大会で優勝］
大学時代はですね
本当にダンスに熱中しました
大学生の全国大会で優勝するくらい
ダンスに熱中して
ダンスとか また音楽というものが
成長していく過程で
大好きだと思えるようになりました
大好きなものに巡り合うことができました
そういう作るのが好きとか
あとはダンスが好きっていう
２つの好きが合わさって生まれた
プロダクトのアイデアがこれだったんですね
これは踊ることによって音を出す と
「めちゃくちゃおもろいやん！」と
アイデアが浮かんだ時はそう思いました
絶対おもろいからちょっと一回
作ってみようと思ったんですね
「作ってみよう！」と
でも当時僕は もう何の経験も
知識もなかったです
で 自分ひとりで
何から始めていいかもわからず
実現が100やとしたら
僕はまさに０の時点からのスタートでした
とりあえず なんかやってみようと思うけど
何から始めたらいいかわからないから
とりあえずこの時代
とりあえず検索してみようということで
「体の動き（スペース）検知」とかですね
「（スペース）センサー」とか
調べてみたんですね
そしたら意外に 作り方が載ってます
どうやって作っていいかとか
結構載ってます
もう今の時代すごいですね
みなさん世界中の人が知識を共有してますね
インターネットで
だから意外に載ってると
「あれ？ これ俺でも作れるぞ！」
というのに気付いて
で このわけわからんけど
このボードとなんかこういう風に
配線したらいいとか
このプログラムを入れたらいい
とかっていうのは載ってたんで
その通りにやってみたら
意外に 体の動きが検知できる装置を
作ることができたんですね
で これが実験の時の ちょっとふざけながら
撮ったやつなんですけど
ここに巻きつけて
こうやって動いてみたんですね
そしたら自分の体の動きに合わせて
センサーの値が変動してる
というのがわかったんで
これは「おやおや！」と
「自分の体の動き
こうやったら検知できるんや！」
ということがわかりました
で ここまでは自分でできたと
ひとりではちょっと限界感じたんで
エンジニアが集まる交流会に参加して
頭良さそうなエンジニアさんを
とにかく探しました
で 見つけたのが彼ですね
すっごい頭 良さそうですね
（笑）
「え？ スマホアプリ作れるんですか？」
って言って
「ちょっと僕 こういうのを
作りたいんですけど
一緒にやりませんか？」と言って
ナンパしたんですね
そしたら多分 僕の勢いに巻き込まれて
「あ いいですよ」みたいな感じで
受け入れてくれました
ようやくチームができてですね
ふたりチームで開発を進めたと
スマホと僕が作ったセンサーと
連動するのが必要だったので
それもやったんですけど
ちょっとまあ これちょっと
難しかったんですけど
やっぱこれも インターネットに載ってるから
結構簡単にできた と
であとは ケース買ってきて詰め込む と
これで完成ですね
プロトタイプ第１号が
なんと２ヶ月ぐらいで
何もない状態から作れました
「あれ？ これ意外にできるやないか？」
というのがここでわかって
試してみました
音が鳴るんですね
動いていたら
「めちゃくちゃおもろい！」と
「すごい楽しい！」と
「やった！」と
いろんな人に
「これ めっちゃ おもろいでしょう！」
って見せまくったんですね
見せて回ったら
親には「お前にはそんなん
どうせ無理やからやめとけ！」とかですね
大学の友達の間で
「あいつ なんかようわからんこと
やり出したらしいで」みたいな
冷ややかな噂が回ったりとか
日本の企業の方に見せても
「これ 誰が何のために使うんですか？」
みたいな感じで言われて
なんか鼻で笑われた 小馬鹿にされた
というようなことも結構あったりして
「マジか？」と思って
「一生懸命作ったのに
こんなに否定されるもんなん？」と思って
「いや違う！」と
「これおもろいっちゅうねん！」と思って
で とにかく馬鹿にされようが
何されようが
もう とにかくいろんな人に見せました
そうするとある日
キーマンのイギリス人の方に出会いました
で そのイギリス人の方
めちゃくちゃ背が高かったんですけど
その方が「これめちゃくちゃ
おもろいやん！」と
「グレートプロダクト！」という英語やから
何を言ってるかわからないんですけど
（笑）
とにかく褒めてくれてるっぽいぞと
「これ絶対海外持っていった方がいいよ」
と言われました
「あ これ日本じゃないんや！」と
「俺の感覚グローバルやん！」って
（笑）
その時 思いました ハイ
で 英語とか全然
しゃべれなかったんですけども
とりあえず海外に行って
その方におもちゃ業界の方を
いろいろ紹介してもらったんですね
で 海外に行って
踊って見せました
（映像）（ロボット音）
得意なロボットダンスを
ふんだんに活かして
（映像）（笑）
こんな感じで
いろんな方に見せたんですけれども
もうみんなとハイタッチしましたね
「すごい！」とこれは
「面白い！」ということで
もう いろんな世界中の方に見せて
で その勢いで香港、ニューヨーク
イギリス、ドイツと
いろんな所を回ったんですね
これを持って
で ニューヨークでは
「ベスト オブ トイフェア」
という賞を頂いたりとか
あとは イギリスでは
テレビ取材を受けたりとか
ものすごい評価をしていただいて
なんと気付けば
もう17カ国でリリースして
出荷台数も40万台突破して
YouTubeの動画再生回数は
なんと400万回再生されて
欧米ではテレビCMまで
やってもらってというような
「え？」と
「え？こんな奇跡起きるんですか？」
っていうぐらいの
動揺するぐらいの奇跡が
なんと起きました
ちょっとこれはびっくりしました
SNS上でも海外から反応がありまして
この方は自分の声を録音して
楽しんでくれています
（笑）
（映像）（両腕の動きに合わせた声）
（映像）（笑）
いやいやいや めちゃくちゃ
嬉しいですよね こういう反応は
で こちらの少年はですね
クリスマスの日に
プレゼントで このプロダクトを
もらった時のリアクションです
［海外での反応］
（少年）（叫び声）
（英語）ワオ！『サウンドムーブズ』だ！
はい
（笑）（拍手）
「（英語）『サウンドムーブズ』だ！」
ってね
ありがとうございます
いや本当に あの
こんな反応してもらって
もう涙が出るほど本当に嬉しくて
てか泣きましたね もう
嬉しくて泣きました
振り返ってみたら
僕がやったことって
中途半端やけどとりあえず
プロトタイプっていうか動くもの作って
それをとにかく見せて回った
でもただそれだけでした
ほんとシンプルに
ただそれだけしか
僕はやってません
で スキルも 僕エンジニアとしても
全然中途半端やし
デザイン力も英語力も全部
今 中途半端なんですね
こんなん言うのも恥ずかしいですけど
全部中途半端です
で ちょっと凹むところ
なんですけれども
いや ちょっと待て と
［いや、中途半端だから］
むしろ中途半端なまま
突き進んだからこそ
誰よりも早く結果を出せて
中途半端な 未完成な
プロトタイプだったからこそ
いろんな人からいろんなフィードバックを
受け入れることができて
より良いプロダクトに仕上がっていった
というふうに思うようになりました
で プロダクト作りめっちゃおもろいなと
ここでちょっと魅力に取り憑かれてですね
新しい挑戦も始めています
それがなんと こちらです
人工知能 AIによる自動作曲ソフト
なんとも難しそうな
内容なんですけども
シーンとムードを選択するだけで
なんと人工知能ちゃんが
曲を作ってくれます
あなただけの曲を作ってくれます
（音楽開始）
なんとも悪そうなこの音楽
これ実は人間じゃなくて
人工知能が作りました
このメロディーとかもですね
このドラムとかも
人工知能がなんと音楽を作る
時代がやってきました
（音楽終了）
で 何が言いたいかというと
ほんの３年ほど前まで
ダメダメだった僕が
今なんとこの人工知能っていう
わけわからないもの—
（笑）
を扱うようになったんですね
当時の多分僕やったら
「人工知能って何ですか？」と
「AIって何ですか？」
「アイって読むんですか？」
みたいな感じのレベルだったと
思うんですけど
なんとこういうことまで
扱うようになったと
で それもこれも３年前
何の知識も経験もない中
なんかようわからんけど
馬鹿にされようが
笑われようが
中途半端やけど一歩踏み出して
本当よかったなぁと
今になって本当に思います
やっぱり「完璧より中途半端の方がいい」
というふうに思うようになりました
もし僕がですよ
僕が一流のエンジニアになってから
作ろうとかですね
あとは完璧に英語を話せるようになってから
海外進出しようとか
もっと大きな企業で経験積んでから
やろうとか そんなん言ってたら
多分そんなん言ってる間に時間経って
多分僕の情熱も冷めていたかもしれないなと
今になってすごく思います
でも一歩踏み出せば
どんどん可能性を広げていって
次のステージ
ネクストステージというふうに
繋がっていくんだなというふうに
すごく今感じています
なので 完璧な第一歩が
未来を開くんじゃなくて
中途半端な第一歩こそ
未来を切り開いていくんじゃないか
というふうに思てます
なので 今後とも僕は中途半端な一歩を
踏み続けようと思っております
こんな中途半端なやつの
話でしたけれども
みなさまの一歩踏み出す勇気に
少しでも繋がれば嬉しく思います
ご静聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）